this morning's cold weather in much of
the country is a reminder that the
holidays and holiday travel are not that
far away believe it or not
Business Insider estimates winter
weather leads to 60,000 flight
cancellations each year in the US and
that means travel problems for millions
of people
mark Elwood a contributing editor at
Conde Nast Traveler has some ideas to
help you handle those cancellations and
maximize your frequent flyer miles in
time for the holiday season so the
weather they call that an act of God
right so you're not gonna get any
sympathy from the airline but if it's a
mechanical problem you've got some
rights how do you utilize them so I was
gonna say remember if it's a weather
cancellation they're canceling for
safety so I know it's frustrating but
they are keep you know keep out I don't
want a flight for a storm exactly when
you get these cancellations what you're
entitled to or what they will tend to
offer you is the next flight on that
airline to your destination yeah but I
always ask there's an industry lingo
called interlining and essentially is
Airlines making nice with each other and
helping each other out right it doesn't
always apply but if you ask nicely you
say hey is there an interlining
agreement you could end up on another
airline but much sooner that's nicely
that's in I never heard of interlining
that's good to know
what's the key to maximizing your
airline miles because what's frustrating
is they have the seats but they don't
have seats for your miles basically
everyone is overwhelmed by it right I
think you think about airline miles and
you think you're always going to do it
wrong
I think they've structured that way
they've made it a real cat-and-mouse
game yeah I always say in real simple
terms try and use airline miles for big
trips sort of bucket list trip long haul
trips you save them up young haul trips
and I would delegate the booking to
those experts there are people who make
frequent flyer miles their hobbies you
can pay someone say 200 bucks and get
them to book on your behalf and they
will work out the best value you can get
how do you find these people well I
would say I would send you somewhere
like award magic or points pros you can
if you google those why do I want to pay
if I already have three miles using the
mouse wisely exactly because I think you
constantly worry you're not getting the
best value if you if you could get a
two-four
one effectively on a business class
flight to Asia boxes well if you have
airline miles but also credit card
models are gonna figure out where you
should put the points track here and
there and mix it all a match as they do
they make it I think they make it
deliberately complicated they have made
it when it started those programs were
very simple people made them a hobby
they had to make them more complicated
it's captain the other the other more
straightforward thing that happens that
really troubles people is you booked a
flight you don't check in then you
finally check in and you get to the
plane and they're like oh actually we
don't have a seat for you avoid that
well that's I mean when you get in
voluntary bumping that's what they
didn't always encourage you check in as
early as you can because that does imply
more of an intention to travel so the 24
hours ahead if that does happen to you
remember the airlines are very unlikely
to just close their arms and say you
can't come on yo they're gonna buy you
off because they had problems with all
of those kind of drama they will stand
at the gate and they will try and sell
you a few vouchers to not be on the
plane yeah I would I would play hard to
get I don't want your stinking vouchers
those gate agents have the power to give
more money than they used to so I would
wait until it's a really sizable amounts
but you know higher higher thank you
mark yeah higher higher I've seen that
happen thank you suppose we'll see him
stand like this no you can't get on
thank you Mark Elwood